ya es calificado como el peor jaque al
gobierno de los eeuu y todavía no ha
terminado desde hace al menos nueve
meses los hackers han llevado a cabo una
sofisticada y muy compleja serie de
ciberataques cuyo alcance está empezando
a saberse ahora usando un software hecho
por la compañía tecnológica solarwinds
los hackers fueron capaces de espiar
tanto a sus usuarios como a los de
microsoft el gigante de los ordenadores
dijo que había detectado el virus en sus
sistemas
es cierto que el número y la
localización de las víctimas crecerá
esto no es una espionaje como de
costumbre incluso en la era digital
el hackeo se ha propagado más allá de
eeuu afectando también a organizaciones
en canadá méxico bélgica españa gran
bretaña israel y los emiratos árabes
unidos- pero washington está lidiando
con la peor caída tecnológica tras
descubrir que el departamento del tesoro
y de comercio están entre los objetivos
del hackeo al igual que el departamento
de energía que es el responsable del
arsenal nuclear estadounidense el
congreso se reunió a puerta cerrada el
viernes para hablar sobre la situación
los expertos en ciberseguridad no están
todavía seguros de cuál ha sido la
magnitud de la intrusión audi en church
nation
hay como unas 18 entidades tanto
privadas como el propio gobierno que se
han comprometido y que tiene el software
de efectos en materia de copyright si
los demócratas han criticado la falta de
respuesta de la administración trampa a
la hora de manejar la crisis muchos
culpan a rusia por el ataque una
acusación que el gobierno ruso ha
desmentido